los musulmanes chiítas celebran este
jueves la sura un ritual anual de duelo
para conmemorar el martirio del tercer
imán el nieto del profeta mahoma en el
ciclo 7 desde irán de mayoría chiita
donde pese al fuerte rebrote de
coronavirus se llevaron a cabo
multitudinarias procesiones fúnebres en
honor al imán hussein irak con una
peregrinación masiva hacia el santuario
de kárbala donde se libró la batalla que
acabó con la vida de hussein un hecho
que marcó el comienzo del cisma entre
chiítas y sunitas las dos principales
ramas del islam hasta líbano bahrein o
pakistán donde la jornada estuvo
empañada por un ataque que deja al menos
tres muertos lo ponemos enferma yo en mi
opinión el mensaje más fuerte es no
aceptar la opresión el altruismo y estar
firmemente basado en la religión del
profeta
pese a la desaprobación de los líderes
chiítas miles de fieles se golpean la
espalda con cuerdas y látigos
flagelándose como expresión simbólica de
arrepentimiento unas imágenes que se
vieron en kabul en afganistán con los
talibán controlando el país y el pánico
entre gran parte de la población afgana
la minoría chiíta de afganistán que
representa el 10 por ciento se aventuró
a salir a las calles para festejar en
varias ciudades señalando que los
insurgentes prometieron respetar los
ritos pese a que en años anteriores han
sido objeto de atentados
hemos asistido a estas ceremonias todos
los años pero con mucho miedo y temor de
que en el momento en que aumente el
número de asistentes exista la
posibilidad de un atentado suicida de
que hayan derramamiento de sangre pero
este año después de saber que los
talibanes están dando seguridad nos
hemos alegrado mucho
son
adicionando
la sura se conmemora el décimo día del
calendario lunar islámico durante el
muharram uno de los meses más sagrados
para las cintas